[Música]
viendo la una y siete de la tarde en
Bogotá quito y Lima continuamos con
nuestro cubrimiento especial con motivo
del primer aniversario de la guerra en
Ucrania bien en este espacio Vamos a
repasar el aspecto mediático de la
guerra en Ucrania porque también ha sido
una batalla informativa y para ello
saludo en el estudio a nuestra compañera
Rosa Pérez Madero Rosa bienvenida Buenos
días Andrés Valentina janetta bueno Rosa
las redes sociales han sido un campo de
desinformación y de propaganda en medio
de esta guerra pero pues este aspecto
mediático claramente ha sido una batalla
informativa exactamente y Les propongo
empezar por recordando momento que
seguro que va a venir enseguida a sus
mentes protagonizado por la periodista
Marina oceanykova a principios de la
guerra
porque hemos querido empezar con este
momento bien porque señala no simboliza
dos cosas que queremos abordar Por un
lado la importancia de las redes
sociales porque este momento se viralizó
y pasó de la televisión rusa que fue
donde tuvo lugar esta protesta a ser
comentado en todo el mundo y por otro
lado porque también señala la censura no
que es contra lo que protestaba la
periodista que por cierto este mes de
febrero Ya vimos reaparecer en la sede
de reporteros Sin fronteras en París a
donde pretende refugiarse bien Pues esta
periodista protagonizaba entre otras
cosas contra la ley que recordemos Rusia
aprobó a principios de la guerra que
persigue hasta con cárcel las ofensas a
contra el ejército Ruso y entre estas
ofensas estaría la cuestión de llamar
guerra a lo que el kre califica
operación militar especial bien esta ley
provocó entre otras cosas que medios
independientes rusos como es el caso de
no vaya galleta quizás el más
paradigmático cesaran directamente las
operaciones pero esta censura No se
reduce solamente al territorio ruso
recordemos que tiene una dimensión
global y vamos a ver con un mapa a
continuación como los distintos bloques
podríamos decirlo así censuraron el
relato del enemigo desde el inicio de la
guerra no el 27 de febrero de 2022 la
Unión Europea veto a sputnik y a RT el 4
de marzo Rusia empezó a vetar medios
occidentales internacionales como las
tienen la bbc France 24 o redes de
sociales sobre todo las de meta o
también por ejemplo Twitter y el 8 de
mayo Estados Unidos
prohibió también Beto las operaciones en
su país de televisiones rusas alineadas
con el kremlin bien y esto Por qué es
importante porque esta censura
digamos que las redes sociales tienen un
papel fundamental a la hora de cómo
accedemos a la información con censura o
sin en un contexto en que se está
restringida la información las redes
sociales todavía cobran más protagonista
protagonismo Disculpen y esto ha sido
fundamental a la hora de explicar la
brecha generacional que hay en Rusia en
términos de acceso a la información
sobre esta guerra esto nos lo comentaba
el periodista del Times James Wars en un
especial que dedicamos a la guerra
informativa en Ucrania no que nos decía
que cuando empezó la guerra y el kremlin
empezó a vetar medios de comunicación
una de las búsquedas más reproducidas en
Rusia en internet era los vpns para
saltarse la censura impuesta por el
kremlin no por eso provoca que los
jóvenes tengan acceso a información que
no está filtrada por las autoridades
rusas también
este vacío informativo que han dejado
los medios tradicionales rusos ha dado
pie en Rusia de los llamados blogueros
proguerra rusos no que sobre todo a
través de Telegram han informado de lo
que sucede en la línea de frente y ellos
son tienen una línea generalmente
patriótica defienden la invasión pero
sin embargo también critican los errores
o las pérdidas que ha sufrido el
ejército ruso en el frente no y es una
comunicación que no está tan controlada
por el kremlin Y por último en la
televisión Estatal a la que acceden más
bien las personas de mediana edad o de
edad avanzada es donde se reproduce un
discurso más alineado con el discurso
oficial ruso entre otras cosas no un
discurso que asimila el gobierno de kiev
con un régimen nazi y para terminar no
con este primer repaso veamos una de las
protagonistas de estas tertulias en las
televisiones rusas que es Margarita
simonían la editora jefe de RT lo que
comentaba a raíz del control de la
información
ninguna gran nación puede existir Sin
Control sobre la información
bien Rosa y hay que recordar también que
veíamos por ejemplo como influencers y
también youtubers se convertían como una
especie de reporteros de guerra
informando desde el día uno de los
bombardeos hasta Cómo se estaban
refugiando en estos túneles y en las
estaciones del metro bien Rosa las redes
sociales también han sido un campo de
desinformación y propaganda exactamente
como lo dices Andrés hemos podido ver
por primera vez quizás a través de
tiktok no como la vida el día a día de
los refugiados ucranianos a través de
Telegram lo que comentábamos no los
blogueros en el frente de la guerra pero
Twitter también Instagram ha sido
escenario de una gran campaña de
propaganda a través de memes hemos
seleccionado El ejemplo de la santa
javelina que es esta virgen no con una
jadelina precisamente este sistema
antitanque es de fabricación
estadounidense con el que cuenta el
ejército ucraniano y es un icono que
simboliza muy bien no está este carácter
ahora mismo bélico ucraniano en el que
se junta el enaltecimiento del
nacionalismo con también la importancia
de la occidental en términos de esta
ayuda tanto económica como bélica no y
es pues desde un meme no que empezó en
redes sociales pero que acabó
convirtiéndose en un mural pintado en la
capital ucraniana en kiev por otro lado
un punto clave del discurso bélico en
las redes sociales han sido las
acusaciones cruzadas de nazismo no los
medios rusos al contrario de los medios
occidentales han dado mucha importancia
en enfatizado mucho el origen neonazi
del Batallón asoff un Batallón que fue
clave en la resistencia ucraniana en
mariopol no prácticamente hace un año y
de hecho hay un episodio señalado que
también comentaba mar en su Crónica de
salud que fue cuando Rusia bombardeó una
hospital maternal en esa ciudad
portuaria en ese momento solamente la
agencia estadounidense asociada Express
era el único medio internacional que
estaba presente en la zona y publicó
unas imágenes que vamos a ver a
continuación que dieron la vuelta al
mundo no y escandalizaron por los ata
que sufrieron civiles particularmente
fue protagonista de estas fotografías
una mujer embarazada y Rusia Cómo
respondió a ese episodio No ya esa
digamos visión que tuvo todo el mundo a
las atrocidades de la guerra Pues bien
dijo que eran un montaje acusaron a esta
mujer de utilizar sus conocimientos en
tanto que influencer de belleza no para
fingir las heridas también dijo Rusia
que en este hospital maternal era un
centro de operaciones del Batallón no y
sin hacer referencia explícita a este
episodio pero digamos con un informe que
se podía relacionar bastante con lo que
sucedió en maripol amnistía
internacional publicó en agosto un
reporte titulado las tácticas de combate
de Ucrania ponen en peligro a sus
civiles al situar bases militares en
áreas residenciales un informe que
generó tanta polémica en Ucrania y en
occidente que llevaron a que amnistía
personal se retractara o más bien
aclarar a su comentario y dijera que
nada justifica la agresión rusa no pero
es un ejemplo también de cómo se ha
blindado tanto el discurso a favor de
Ucrania no y en oposición a la agresión
Rusia rusa que cualquier crítica sea
tomada de forma un poco digamos
mal intencionada no Rosa algo que
tenemos que analizar y que podemos
analizar bastante bien Podría decirlo
los comunicadores es la forma de
comunicar que dista muchísimo de los dos
presidentes de estos dos países que son
bolodirse lensky por un lado y Vladimir
Putin por el otro Así es Valentina y es
una diferencia tan clara que se expresa
Incluso en los atuendos no vemos a
Vladimir Putin normalmente impoluto con
un traje y siempre digamos utiliza unos
escenarios muy podríamos decir solemnes
no Palacios estas grandes mesas unas
grandes distancias como la el salón la
mesa Lo separó de Manuel macron una
imagen que también se convirtió
enseguida en un meme que se viralizó en
las redes o incluso cuando se junta con
el pueblo en la plaza roja lugares así
lo hace desde una posición de mucha
distancia no dirigiéndose como líder
digamos
incuestionable mientras que vuelo de
lens que ha adoptado una posición
diametralmente distinta siempre con esta
camiseta militar
publicando vídeos en las redes sociales
de forma prácticamente diaria
manteniéndose en ese búnker como un
líder que no abandona su pueblo no que
está al frente de la reacción digamos de
la resistencia ucraniana y de hecho no
abandonó Ucrania durante muchísimos
meses eran los líderes aliados los que
iban a visitarle a kiev de hecho hasta
kiev fue la propia revista vogue no
donde recordemos que la primera dama
obleas de lensca protagonizó junto a
selensky un reportaje en esa revista que
causó mucha polémica y por otro lado no
en comentábamos es el que no salió
durante mucho tiempo pero sí que ya el
20 de diciembre protagonizó su primer
viaje fuera de Ucrania desde que empezó
la guerra y se desplazó en ese caso a
Estados Unidos porque es que esta guerra
No se podría entender sin el apoyo de
Washington Y de forma más general de la
otan no aquí es el curso de la guerra
habría sido sin duda radicalmente de
distinto y bien en este sentido es
también importante destacar el rol que
han tenido los medios de comunicación a
la hora de legitimar este apoyo
occidental a Ucrania No si bien Es
verdad que es una cuestión de alianzas
no y de oposición a Rusia y es una
cuestión geopolítica el propio papel de
lensky como actor al frente de su país
ha sido también clave no a la hora de
poner a Ucrania en el punto central de
la agenda internacional y esto digamos
lo resumió muy bien el editor jefe de la
revista Time cuando eligieron a
bolodimers que como persona del año en
2022 dijo su ofensiva informa tiva
cambió el clima del sistema geopolítico
desencadenando una oleada de acción que
sacudió al mundo bien antes de continuar
Yo quiero analizar este tema con nuestra
invitada Anita todos estos elementos que
Rosa menciona hacen de boladimir Celeste
en su territorio como un símbolo de
determinación de pureza Pero cómo se
percibe la imagen de Vladimir Putin en
territorio ruso
redimir Putin en el territorio ruso
sigue siendo el líder fuerte que
exactamente quiere el pueblo ruso hoy y
siempre ha querido en su historia atrás
por eso están los zares emperadores los
jefes del Estado comunistas hasta Putin
en este momento Si no es fuerte y líder
ahí está ahí la crítica con gourmet que
supuestamente se cayó Unión soviética
porque no era este líder fuerte No hay
manera como representar la nación y la
nación se identifica no solo con el
líder con un tipo de ideología que hoy
en día es vamos a decir más conservadora
porque un mundo liberal occidental es
criticado y supone con una idea de un
mundo más conservador donde hay ideales
que vienen de una familia conserva donde
no hay posibilidades de verse variedades
y una iglesia ortodoxista como un Pilar
para este tipo de política Así que
muchas veces cuando escucho Paulina en
ruso y analizo sus discursos él responde
a lo que le gusta al pueblo ruso vamos a
decir en su mayoría porque es muy
peligroso concluir generalizando que
todos son así siempre hay gente que
piensa de otra manera y se siente
profundamente en este momento indignado
por la guerra pero Putin lo hace muy
bien para los rusos están orgullosos por
lo que él hace en este momento le
responden sinceramente que están
dispuestos de ir hasta el final porque
defender la causa de esta operación
militar especial Rosa también la entre
las narrativas de ambos bloques no solo
es la forma sino que hay un enorme
discrepancia en el fondo Exactamente no
lo que comentábamos no es solo una
cuestión de cómo se presentan ante sus
respectivas poblaciones ni ante el mundo
sino también una cuestión de narrativas
ya para cerrar este espacio dos
narrativas completamente opuestas que
quedaron muy claras en la asamblea
general de Naciones Unidas el pasado mes
de septiembre cuando tanto el
representante ruso sergei labrov
ministro de exteriores de Rusia como el
presidente
ucranianonski apelaron al mismo artículo
51 de la carta de Naciones Unidas la que
recoge el derecho a la legítima defensa
para defender su acción bélica en el
conflicto actual escuchemos y con eso yo
ya termino
y hemos visto Quién es el único que
quiere la guerra
la falta de decisión de los países
occidentales y la guerra continua del
régimen de kiev contra su propio pueblo
no nos dejó más que lanzar una operación
militar especial para proteger a los
rusos y eliminar las amenazas a nuestra
seguridad que la otan ha creado
sistemáticamente en territorio ucraniano
Ucrania ha mostrado fortaleza en el
campo de batalla utilizando su derecho a
la legítima defensa de acuerdo con el
artículo 51 de la carta de la ONU
la operación se lleva a cabo en
cumplimiento de los tratados de amistad
cooperación y asistencia mutua entre
Rusia y estas repúblicas sobre la base
del artículo 51 de la carta de Naciones
Unidas